alors des candidates et des candidats ou
comédiens à votre avis la question est
la question est posée
tiens il ya ben alors moi je pense pas
du tout que ce soit des comédiens ayant
fait cette télé réalité après
effectivement il ya des choses qu'on
apprend à force base dans une télé c'est
à dire qu'il ya une caméra donc on sait
comment se tenir
on sait qu'on a camera commence à
tourner mais c'est comme ici sur un
plateau s'appelle l'école a ouais je
vais pas me retourner alors qu'est la
caméra qu'elle a donc on apprend
certaines joueuses effectivement j'en ai
fait 7 mai j'ai jamais eu un seul rift
ouais mais j'ai jamais eu oui ça fait un
peu beaucoup non mais ça messieurs a par
contre c'est un métier je revendique
c'est un métier mais je suis pas actrice
se quand j'arrive dans une télé réalité
on ne donne pas un script en disant
voilà aujourd'hui tu as un scénario tu
dois draguer intel pardon parce que ça
je suis jaloux pardon c'est pas cette
émission d'une même d'un même programme
ses sept programmes différents
j'ai fait sept acteurs de complément
actrice alors c'est quoi votre métier
bah justement je pense qu'on devrait
avoir un nom pour nous qualifier je
pense qu'on vend du rêve aux gens c'est
du divertissement c'est pour ça que
c'est des programmes de divertissement
c'est bien le nom maintenant oui c'est
un métier mais on n'est pas acteur parce
qu'on n'a pas un script le matin je me
réveille pas en disant bon bah alors
aujourd'hui je vais à les embrouiller
intel je vais aller en braille a hâte de
soi même on le fait ça quand même de la
mets toi si je demandais musical
organisé classerie merde je vous
rappelle que vous êtes aujourd'hui à
midi j'ai des consignes de monsieur
hanouna et briques non moi je pense
qu'on a vu c'est que oui et c'est que
j'ai fait discret ce soir et huit pages
vient d'animer le prime des anges qui
est diffusée dimanche donc j'étais sur
le tournage il ya une semaine donc je
peux vous raconter un peu comme comment
ça se passe
moi je pense qu'on a fait une rupture
avec l'enfermement c'est qu'au départ on
avait des téléréalités il est enfermé
sans téléphone sans rien et là on passe
vite
dudu in ou out duo nov et ça on peut
avoir l'impression que c'est truqué mais
pas du tout on ne peut pas les empêcher
de se parler avant effectivement le
tournage connaissait pas truc les bras
de sa tombe pas un peu en rond alors ça
peut des fois des histoires qui
reviennent parce que c'est pas notre vie
combien de fois que vous
revenu vers vos ex par exemple ça ça
risque est la règle générale quand même
et j'ai l'impression que de plus en plus
on retrouve les mêmes codes les portes
qui claquent des français qui sont
inhérentes à la vie de tous les jours je
suis d'accord monsieur monsieur montiel
oui et votre vieil âge vous vous quirant
quant à jean dit plutôt les gagants
chérie nous sommes solidaires tous les
deux succès non moi je voulais me dire
une chose je ne suis pas intéressé par
ces émissions du tout je le regrette je
vous respecte la mademoiselle et toi
aussi aimerait que tu le sais ouais en
revanche je ne suis pas intéressé
pourquoi parce que justement ça manque
de naturel maintenant tous ces jeunes
qui rentrent qu'ils sont beaux tout ce
que vous voulez mais ils connaissent
tous les codes c'est la recherche du
buzz
ils ont tout compris raison alors je
suis content que vous avez un statut
d'intermittent peut-être non que maître
assous à la non salariés ils sont ils
sont intermittents mais vit tous à dubaï
mais pas beau il ya quelqu'un qui vivent
à dubaï donc ça c'est pas pareil pour
les infos avant que l'on débat c'est
vrai que quand je dis que ça tourne en
rond on regarde des émissions c'est un
peu toujours la même chose on s'engueule
on se rabiboche on aime à gauche on aime
à droite on est au milieu et finalement
on n'aime personne ne sait pas ce que tu
as fait avec moi qui s'est passé
écoutons m
pas
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas parce qu'un lot de fidèles si
c'est pas avec moi c'est contre moi je
m'attache à hisser les voiles bretois un
camp d'un conjoint décédé tombés
d'accord pour maintenir pas en avant
mais l'anniversaire de ma mère casse les
[Rires]
c ça vous laisse bouche bée ces images
s'amener se bouge mais moi j'ai fait une
télé réalité j'ai fait la ferme la
première c'était beau mais là ce qui
avait de bien c'est qu'on ne savait pas
du tout ce que ça allait donner
ce que ça allait être donc les gens que
des supports encore les codes et on
devait faire des choses on apprenait des
choses et ça a permis de faire une
émission qui s'est très très bien passé
moi ça m'a intéressé parce que la ferme
c'est la base de toute nation de tous
pays
c'est en achètent pour les petits le
livre avec les animaux de la ferme et
tous et moi j'ai trouvé ça génial des
conditions précaires
après bon ça il y avait des poils
édition c'était naturel combat